Speaker 1: There are two major parties in the
United States in politics. There's Republicans
and there's Democrats. That's the situation right
now. Those are the two major parties. And for
about five years now, basically since 2016, the
Republican Party has become the party of Trump,
controlled by Trump, taken over by Trump, other
flavors of Republicans and increasingly pushed to
the margins. Yeah, it's globally embarrassing
for the U.S.. Yeah, it's completely shameful,
but it is the reality. The Republican Party has
become mostly the party of Trump. In thinking
about the future, we've been wondering, will the
Republican Party continue to be the party of Trump
or are they going to abandon that? We're not
really going to get our first major data point
until November of 2022 when the midterm elections
actually take place, will be able to see do
the Trumpy and incumbents get reelected? Do the
Trump endorsed candidates win that type of thing
in November of 2002? But short of those
results we just received in the last week,
two pretty important data points that could signal
a declining influence of Trump ism. What are the
two data points? Well, first of all, last week we
had the California gubernatorial recall election.
It was heavily pushed forward by pro Trump
Republicans in California. The primary alternative
to the incumbent governor, Gavin Newsom, was
nothing short of a Trump clone in Larry Elder.
And the Republicans got crushed 64 to 36, just a
massive defeat. This is basically the same margin
as Joe Biden's 20-20 win in California of 63 to
34. And in a recall, usually those calling for
the recall are highly motivated to vote. And yet
they still got crushed by the same margin that
Biden defeated Trump in California in last year's
election. Usually you would expect a tighter
race in that case. In a sense, that was a mini
referendum on Donald Trump and it went absolutely
terribly for the pro Trump California Republicans.
So that's a data point. No one from last week.
Secondly, over the weekend, we had this completely
failed pro Trump riot or rally in Washington, D.C.
and people like Congressman Ted
Lieu and others have been saying
the pathetic turnout shows the waning influence
of Donald Trump now alone. I don't think these
two data points really tell us what we need to
know about Trump ism in the Republican Party.
But they are interesting data points. Regardless
importantly, even if we believed that these were
real, true, bona fide signs of Donald Trump's
declining influence, it would not be a signal
for us to just sit back. So in that sense,
it's irrelevant. This is going to be a long
process in the best of cases, and ultimately
it's going to come down to the 2022 election.
If Republicans lose seats somehow and if
Trump is lose, it may be the end of the
clown show locally. They might still do OK. But
nationally, you could see in November of 2002,
the Republican Party, if they if they get crushed,
they will probably go back to something other than
Trump ism, something marginally less bad, still
bad, but marginally less bad. And Trump may see
those 2022 results as a sign that he should not
run in 2024. Now, the alternative is Trump is
do well in 2022 or even if Trump is, don't do
that well. But Republicans gain in the House,
take the House. It might still encourage Trump to
say, I think I'm going to go for it in 2024. So
for now, even if Trump is losing influence, Trump
ism is. Still very much alive, most Republicans
still repeat his talking points, they still
fearmonger the way that he does. They still
placate the it's rigged ideology and the type
of people. Now, there's one other side to this.
There were some is saying don't go to the
D.C. rally this weekend. It's a false flag.
They're going to use it to entrap you. The FBI
is actually setting it up. Now, in that sense,
if that's what kept people away to the point where
only a few dozen actually showed up. It may also
not be the signal that we imagine it to be. But
there are some cautious reasons to wonder. Is
the influence of Trump ism waning, as evidenced
over the last two weeks, over the last week by the
pathetic turnout over the weekend at the Justice
for J. Six rally and the humiliating, disastrous
defeat for Republicans in California. Let me know
what you think. How valuable, how important are
these data points in these signals? You can find
me on Twitter at David Pakman. Remember that our
program is mostly funded by viewers and listeners
like you who sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom,
we do an extra show every day, if you like this
show even at all. I mean, come on, if you like
it at all, you can get an extra show every single
day by signing up at Join Pakman Dotcom. You can
also use the coupon code better twenty one to get
a discount off of the membership of your choice